so one of the things we're saying is how
do the israelis bring their version
of judaism here to american jews and how
can we as american jews export that
to israel that's one of the things we
need to think about right
[Music]
zach bodner thank you so much for
joining me on 20 minute leaders
it's my pleasure thank you for inviting
me michael you know when i look at you i
think of the person that's allowing me
to get
israeli entertainment in palo alto
because when
before corona times i would come almost
weekly to the jcc
for the weekly israeli artist i know
that i may be
experiencing the gcc different than a
lot of other people around the community
but that's you know you gave me such a
great gift so first of all thank you
it's really great it's my pleasure and
i'm glad you're taking advantage of all
of the opportunities we're offering
or at least one of the many
opportunities we're offering and
in this time of lockdown we're doing a
virtual ofjcc and the israeli stuff
that's happening on facebook live is
phenomenal so i hope you're taking
advantage of that as well
but there's a lot of other stuff you
could be doing as well michael and when
we open up
hopefully sometime soon i'm happy to
share with you what those are as well
i would love that zach he's been
involved you know on the intersection of
of
israel america judaism for so long but
actually
you started off by playing varsity
soccer in yale
yes i don't know if that's where i
started but i definitely started at a
certain point there yes and
i did i went to yale to uh to get the
great education that yale offers and to
play soccer i was recruited to play
soccer there i played goalie
and it was an incredible experience i
actually took a little bit of a break i
went
and studied at hebrew university in
jerusalem for one semester
my my junior year at the rothberg school
and
um and while i was there i actually
played with hapoelius uh so played a
little bit of ball with them
wait you played professionally with the
polio shirley not officially because i
was playing ncaa ball
in ncaa is uh the national collegiate
athletic association so when you're
playing
actually my girlfriend at stanford just
won the national championship this year
great but so i trained with them i
trained with apple well i didn't uh play
officially with them but
it was a great experience that's what
changed my life the time in israel i met
the woman who i ended up
marrying became my wife and made the
best friends of my life i came back and
i realized this is what i wanted to do
with my life something related to israel
and the jewish people so what did you
study at yale
i studied psychology and i i focused on
psychology of religion
i've always been a seeker i've always
been kind of a jew in the wilderness
right looking for the answers and so
this was kind of like why
do people ask these big life questions
and i thought
why does the dog howl at the moon you
know these are the sorts of questions
that i was always asking it led me to
ultimately do graduate school work in
philosophy of religion
and theology which is highly marketable
let me tell you what you're doing with
gsb
is going to get you a much better job
out of graduate school than what i did
with a graduate degree in theology
michael
amazing i definitely gsb is definitely
my raider right now i'm still i'm still
in the undergrad but but i love that a
lot of people think that i'm in the gsb
so
so right now it's it's like you know
planting seeds in my mind that i i know
i can get there and i'll get there one
day
exactly exactly i think it's your
maturity having spent time in the army
you know you're older than most of the
the young students at stanford i think
i i i hope together one day and i just
love it i am trying to take a bunch of
gsb courses because you know it's
just the building next door but that's
for another topic zach i want to talk
for a second about judaism 4.0 you had a
great tedx talk
that you gave about it and i loved the
very first sentence that you said
you said judaism is a lot of things but
at the same time it's none of those
things so
please give me a little bit of insight
into what what is this judaism 4.0
yeah right well judaism is it's a
religion it's not a religion it's a
people it's not a people it's a
ethnicity it's not an ethnicity it's a
moral code it's a culture right it's all
of the above and none of the above it's
it's 3 000 years old and yet people are
still confused by
what judaism is and that's because it's
evolved over time
and i talk about 4.0 michael because i
believe we're in the fourth era
of judaism the first era was the era of
the mishkan when we were wandering in
the desert
and our portable holiness went with us
2.0 we settled
in israel the holy land we built a
temple it was destroyed
built the next temple it was destroyed
but that period of centrality
our spirituality was had a home and then
destroyed 70 ce you know the story and
ever since then we've been in the 3.0
era
which is the dispersion the exile right
but what's happening and ever since kind
of the enlightenment
is judaism has started to realize that
it can also be a part of secular society
too
right and this is what's confused people
about is it is it a religion or is it
not a religion
um how can you convert out and yet how
can the nazis still say well you're
jewish even if you converted right like
does it mean there's a blood issue
there's an ethnicity well now we know
that jews can also be
asian they can be an african-american
they can be latino right
it's not just about yiddish it's not
oshko-normative right as we think about
there's safari i heard a nice safari
girl i like that
yeah so we're now in this moment of of
4.0 or on the cusp
um and it's it's a lot of different
factors that are contributing to this
moment but it's creating a sociological
crash
right our whole outlook um has been
flipped on its head
so we have to ask ourselves what is the
judaism of the future going to look like
so our job our vision at the jccc here
in palo alto
is to be the architects of the jewish
future we consider ourselves
to be the ones helping people think
about how can they do
jewish their way so michael you came and
you connected to your israeliness
here at the jcc right and so one of the
things we're saying is how do the
israelis bring their version of judaism
here to american jews and how can we as
american jews export that
to israel that's one of the things we
need to think about right because
a lot of israelis as you probably know
think that you're either secular
or you're orthodox and don't recognize
there's a lot in between
right in american judaism has this whole
mosaic in between
yeah right but uh but if israelis can
see that here and bring that back so
i'll give you an example right
some israelis who come here experience
american judaism
they saw what a reform jewish synagogue
a friday night service could be like and
they went back and they brought that to
the namau
in tel aviv on the port and now you go
on a friday night
yes beautiful service right mixed men
and women and singing and
israelis are like what is this right
that's an is an israeli import from
american judaism
right by the same token i think we in
america we need to import
the idea of the mecchina program the
idea of jewish service that all israelis
like you served in the army
how can we do this for american jews so
they feel like they're a part of
something in a community
and not just i've had my bar mitzvah was
though i'm done
right now i think i think one of the
things that i was exposed that is
through j ventures which were also in lp
of an
and the fund that we're both involved
with but i came to the room and you have
about a hundred
you know partners in the room all
incredible executives and investors
a lot how a lot of them israelis a lot
of them american jewish
and all of a sudden you know i believe
there were some americans there who said
that
this is their first interaction with
israelis israelis all of a sudden are
are communicating with with american
jews and not just you know in the
sunnyvale kibbutz
so i think that i'm learning also that
there are these huge differences and one
of the things that i was exposed to was
the idea that
you know as an israeli i don't remember
the last time my friends and i really
visited the synagogue in israel
yet a lot of my jewish friends here it's
it's kind of a thing
to go to synagogue and it's and you know
almost i feel like you're more jewish
than i am and i i'm very jewish so
it's it's really interesting to see all
these different cultures come together
right i think that what you're
experiencing and being a part of with j
ventures and
uh and at the jcc is this
acknowledgement that we can learn from
each other and be a part of each other's
worlds
and give and take spiritually culturally
religiously and then we can
we can love each other as a family even
if we disagree
right and this is the part that i i fear
actually michael is that this next
generation of young american jews
are only judging their relationship with
israel
through the two things that they have
issues with right the
israel's treatment of the palestinians
and also the chief rabbit in israel
the two things that many american jews
disagree with that's how they're the
whole lens through which they view
israel
is through those two things and and i'm
saying no no the relationship with
israel is much bigger
much more beautiful much longer lasting
and much more complicated and you have
to kind of transcend those differences
and by the same token i'm saying to
israeli jews don't just look at us as
failed zionists because we don't have
the chutzpah don't just look at us as
saying
you're not even going to be jewish in a
few generations because of inner
marriage or assimilation or
anti-semitism right so we're talking
past each other
and what you're seeing with
organizations like j ventures or the
work we're doing here at the jcc is this
integration the weaving together of
israeli jews
and american jews and it's making all of
us better and that way
if something happens like in the next
few weeks with with annexation michael
you know there's going to be a
especially in the liberal bay area
there's going to be a lot of
service for american jews around what's
happening in israel but if you love
israel and you recognize that they have
to make some tough decisions that maybe
we don't agree with
and and we have every right to talk
about our positions on these but
don't let it define your entire
relationship with israel right
figure out how just like when you're
sitting around the shabbat table michael
with your your crazy uncle larry
who has crazy views you know maybe he's
a trump lover and you're not or maybe he
hates trump and you love trump but
you're still family and you have to
figure out how to sit around the
shabbos table the pesach table and
embrace each other even if you're
arguing
this is what jews have done for
generations the mahloket
right we've never agreed on each other
yeah two you put two jews in a room you
get
three different opinions exactly exactly
zach
talk to me a little bit about where are
we headed you know you're seeing the
you're seeing these trends you were a
part of aipac for many many years
and in leadership positions both of the
jcc may back where
where are we headed you know let's let's
say 10 years from now or 20 years from
now are there big changes are there
different trends
optimism pessimism yeah i think that
there are um
trends that can go either way frankly
number one um
we're seeing institutional affiliations
dropping
right so membership in american
synagogues is dropping
the old legacy institutions um are
dropping
and you have the older generation of
jews who are ringing their hands and
trying to vault and worried
but they shouldn't be because this next
generation your generation
they're not walking away from judaism
they're starting up
new cool jewish ways of doing right
there's the urban adamah and there's
moisha house and there's wilderness
torah and there's at the well
but there's also this ethos of the
jewish
tikun alam social action right jews are
doing jewish by getting involved
with the racial justice movement and
right so they're still doing jewish so
but the dropping of institutional
affiliation is going to change the
landscape
that's a trend that we have to watch out
for the second trend is
the ethnographics are shifting michael
which means that it's no longer about
are you ashkenazi are you safarti like i
said right there there are jews of color
um i have i'll tell you a story there's
a japanese woman on our board of
directors here
at the jcc she's not jewish she didn't
convert she married a jewish guy
the jewish guy he doesn't really care
about doing jewish
he's happy that his wife cares she's the
one who's doing it she's japanese
and she's the one driving the kids to
hebrew school she's the one who doesn't
makes khala she's the one who does the
passover cedar so tell me who's jewish
in that relationship
right right the future is going to
belong to those people who
choose to do we're all going to be jews
of by choice right we're all going to be
jews by choice
that's another trend that we have to pay
attention to the third is this is the
first time ever
ever ever in jewish history when there's
both a strong jewish
homeland in israel and a strong jewish
diaspora
mainly here in america there's been one
or the other but now we have both and
figuring out how we work together
it goes back to what i was saying before
we have to find a way to transcend
our differences these trends are going
to be incredibly important and the last
thing i'll say is
also the doesn't it feel so that the the
jews and the best for
the centralized ones in the us it still
feels pretty fragmented no you have a
strong
centralization of jews in let's say in
new york and then you have in palo alto
and you have
maybe north so so do you consider that
centralized or is that also because you
know the distance from here to new york
is just as great as you know from israel
to london
it's it's true but those distances are
breaking down now because of the ability
to do exactly what you and i are doing
right now
and that speaks to what i think is the
last biggest trend
uh science and technology the massive
pace and speed with with science and
technology are changing everything
look you and i can have this
conversation even though we're just a
couple of miles away from each other but
we could do this with folks in israel
you can have a haredi woman and a
secular man or vice versa actually
talking like this now
right across time zones across um
you can have age no it also it's it goes
away
all of a sudden so yes there's a central
place here in palo alto and a central
place in new york
but we're breaking down these barriers
now and so think about how we can now
have real talmud study
with the chavruta that's sitting
thousands and thousands of miles away
okay think about how science and
technology are changing things so it's
not just a shabbos elevator
in jerusalem michael but what if tesla
allows for a shabbos car
so now we can you know drive on shabbos
imagine if they're now figuring out how
to make these impossible burgers
and this plant-based meat so imagine now
that we can have actually kosher pork
and kosher bacon like you know science
is changing everything and those are the
those are the small things uh but but
imagine the big things as well imagine
when virtual reality
allows us to actually stand at the base
of mount sinai and experience
revelation for ourselves right so so
time goes away
space goes away science and technology
is changing everything and those are the
positive trends
but it can also have a dark side as well
you know the
the the for example the genetic testing
if somebody says well you can now test
whether you are genetically jewish or
not
and that means you're either in or out
that can i could see that going in a
very very dark
and scary no no obviously i mean in
israel there's al there's a bunch of
different conflicts and you know just as
a testament
tel aviv just recently very recently
announced that
uh that gay couples can be can declare
themselves married and get the benefits
of being married which is a huge
huge incredible feat that they managed
to get to get through finally
but you know i have also witnessing in
israel that there is a great a greater
conflict emerging between secular jews
and religion jews
within israel with between you know the
regular you know
citizens and then the charades and one
of the amazing things that i've been
observing through technology
and and and such is moshe friedman from
brene brock
and you know within here he brings on
this
amazing group of heredi technology
enthusiasts and creates this venture
capital arm
in brave rock bringing together also
people from tel aviv and creating this
mishmash
and showing that yes we're actually not
that different sure one one eats pork
the other one doesn't but
we're all we're all the same people at
the end and i think it's beautiful zach
we have just a few minutes left
i want to get you your mind about
leadership a little bit because you have
you know dozens of years of experience
it with leadership and i'd love to get
your point on
on leadership as a whole thank you
michael um
and uh it's been a great conversation i
love the way that you've made this
happen
uh it's very grassroots and it's it's
very indicative of what's gonna happen
this next generation right no longer
do you have to have somebody hectoring
you blessing you saying you are now
a leader therefore you get to interview
whomever you it's going to come up and
bubble up
organically grassroots the way you have
so um
i love that you're an example of this
and thank you for inviting me to be part
of this conversation
uh look leadership takes all forms as we
know um and then people talk about
peacetime
leaders and wartime leaders uh peacetime
ceos wartime ceos
and and you have to take on different
personality types
for different environments i i think
about what a real leader has to do
and what a real leader doesn't have to
do and i have this uh i have this
acronym
it just happens to be the word
scaffolding i think a real strong leader
has to offer the scaffolding and allow
the rest of his or her team
to do the rest and what does the
scaffolding entail the s you have to
offer the strategy
how can you be the one thinking about
what it's going to take to achieve the
goals of the organization the c
you have to change the culture and set
the culture and determine are you going
to micromanage or you can give people a
lot of freedom is going to be a culture
of shared leadership
or not okay i think the a is the
architecture
what does the setup of the organization
look like what does the org chart look
like who reports to whom
right f focus you have to provide the
focus
so that people aren't wandering off um
but you also have to allow people a
little bit of autonomy in that
the second f is forecasting you have to
be able to see the future
right people are looking for what is the
future what's right around the bend i
mean some of the questions you asked me
right the o is for oversight
and determining what oversight are you
going to measure daily metrics weekly
kpis
monthly quarterly what does that look
like right
the l is for leadership okay leadership
development
and that's not just kind of like the
generic way but who are you looking to
in the future
to bring on to your board of directors
to be your next round of investors
right who is who's your kitchen cabinet
that's leadership development not just a
one-man show but who are the people that
are going to help you
and and help the whole organization lead
with you right
exactly i is inspiration in many ways
the ceo has to be the c
i o the chief inspiration officer right
the
n is for network because you are the guy
at the top or the woman at the top and
you are the only one who could talk to
other leaders at that level so you are
the one who keeps that network in your
own industry
right that so the network is the end and
finally the last is the g
which is the golden circle simon sinek
has this great ted talk you've probably
seen it about the golden circle
yeah we all have to sell from the center
of the circle which is the y so you as
the leader have to provide the why
what is the reason why you are doing
whatever you're doing
so that's how i think about leadership
and anything outside of that acronym
i leave it to the rest of the team zach
why are you doing what you're doing why
are you
and the ceo of the jcc in palo alto
why why because this is my calling this
is what i meant to do
really this is in my in my kishkas it's
it's it's
what i meant to be doing at this time in
my life i took this job i left it i
loved apac
i ran the pacific northwest region of
apac for almost 15 years
um i loved it i didn't want to leave but
when somebody approached me about this
opportunity i realized that i actually
believe the next hundred years of
american jewish life michael
is going to be built by the jews out
here the last hundred years of american
jewish life
was built by east coast jews everything
that we know from the synagogue
structures the
the legacy institution infrastructure
new york jewish delhi defined our food
right
jewish humor came from the borscht belt
in broadway but the next hundred years
of american jewish life it's gonna be
built by the jews out here
because they have the resources they're
the ones who are disenfranchised with
the way that we used to do jewish and
they want to change it up
and they have the willingness to break
glass
move fast think like silicon valley
entrepreneurs so those three things
mean that these jews out here are going
to create the next generation of jewish
life
they may not know it yes but i but i
want to be a part of that
conversation i want to help them think
about what it means to do that that's
why i'm in this role
i love it i love it zach last question
the most important one
i need three words that you would use to
define yourself
or any of your colleagues at the jcc or
apac would
use to define zach bodner um
[Music]
good question i think passionate as you
could probably hear from me i'm
passionate about
life about the causes that i attach
myself to about the people in my
world so number one is passionate i
think number two is genuine
uh i i always have to be myself even if
that means
sharing bad news uh as i've had to do in
this last week with
the changes that are coming at the jcc
because of our budget situation
yeah and i think finally
the last word i would use to describe
myself is um
gregarious i'm a people person i like to
be out there i like to engage
i like to which is why this this
lockdown and the social distancing is so
hard for me in particular right it's
this is this way of connecting is is
great but it doesn't replace
i want to give you a hug michael i want
to just be able to sit and break bread
with you i want to share a drink with
you
and so being the gregarious extrovert
that i am it's very hard for me
in this situation but i think those are
at least some of the words i would use
to describe myself
i love it zach thank you so so much i
love that you're on jabutinski street
right now
thank you for the inspiration and for
the time i learned so much uh so thank
you
thank you michael appreciate you
inviting me thank you and i'll see you
at the gcc
one day one coroner is over one day god
willing
all right take care thanks